David Boder: [In German] Sei können jüdisch oder deutsch reden, wie Sie wollen.
Julian Weinberg: Hm.
David Boder: Von wo sind Sie jetzt gekommen?
Julian Weinberg: Ich bin gekommen von...aus Lodz.
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: Polen.
David Boder: Polen. Wie ist Ihr voller Name?
David Boder: [In English] August 17, 1946. Paris, Grand Hotel. Spool Number 49. An Illinois Institute of Technology recording. The interviewee is with the engineer Julian Weinberg from Lodz, Poland.
David Boder: [In German] Also Herr Weinberg, wollen Sie mir nochmals sagen, was ist Ihr Name und von wo sind Sie?
Julian Weinberg: Mein Name ist Julian Weinberg aus Lodz, Polen.
David Boder: Was tun Sie jetzt in Lodz, Herr Weinberger?
Julian Weinberg: Jetzt bin ich Leitender Direktor des Elektrizitätswerkes Lodz.
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: Das ist...das ist eines der größten Elektrizitätswerke Polens.
David Boder: Ja. Sagen Sie mal, waren Sie auch vor dem Kriege mit diesen Werken verbunden?
Julian Weinberg: Ja, vor dem Kriege habe ich auch gearbeitet in diesem Werke seit 1911.
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: Und im Jahre, in diesem Jahre neunzehn hundert sechs und vierzig (1946) habe ich das fünf und dreißig (35) jährige Jubiläum meiner Arbeit in diesem Elektrizitätswerke gefeiert.
David Boder: Ja. Aber Sie sehen aus, wie ein ganz junger Mensch, Herr Weinberg! Wie alt sind Sie?
Julian Weinberg: Ich bin geboren achtzehn hundert neunzig (1890)...
David Boder: Aha.
Julian Weinberg: . . . ich bin sechs und fünfzig (56) Jahre alt.
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: Und als ein und zwanzig (21) jähriger junger Mann habe ich bereits den Posten eines Ingenieurs in dem Elektrizitätswerk Lodz übernommen
David Boder: Also das war noch...[beide sprechen]
Julian Weinberg: Gleich nach...das war neunzehn hundert elf (1911)—das heißt kurz nach meinem Studium.
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: Studiert habe ich in Paris. War ich...habe ich studiert Mathematik, das war auf der Sorbonne und dann habe ich das Polytechnikum in Nancy absolviert.
David Boder: Also, Sie waren noch Ingenieur zur Zeit wo Polen Russland war?
Julian Weinberg: Jawohl, ganz richtig.
David Boder: Ja. Deswegen weil Sie Jude waren, waren Sie angestellt dort?
Julian Weinberg: Ja, wenn Polen noch an Russland gehörte.
David Boder: Nun, sagen Sie mal, Herr Weinberg...
Julian Weinberg: Das war das Kongress Polen.
David Boder: Ja. Ich bin ein bisschen nervös, denn Sie wollen mir nicht mehr als eine halbe ( ½ ) Stunde geben und ich weiß, dass Sie sehr viel zu erzählen haben. Darum möchte ich Sie Folgendes bitten. Beantworten Sie ein paar Fragen. Wo waren Sie, wenn die Deutschen Polen...also nach Polen rein kamen?
Julian Weinberg: Im letzten Krieg?
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: Da war ich in Lodz.
David Boder: Sie waren in Lodz auf Ihrer Stelle?
Julian Weinberg: Auf meiner Stelle, ja.
David Boder: Wie lange haben Sie die Deutschen zufrieden gelassen? Wie lange haben Sie gearbeitet nachdem die Deutschen gekommen sind?
Julian Weinberg: Nachdem die Deutschen gekommen sind, habe ich gearbeitet...
David Boder: Nun?
Julian Weinberg: . . . hm, zwei (2) Monate.
David Boder: Zwei Monate.
Julian Weinberg: Zwei Monate. Und dann wurde unser Werk durch einen SS Mann übernommen...
David Boder: Hm.
Julian Weinberg: . . . und ich musste—als Jude—musste ich meinen Posten verlassen. Also...
David Boder: Und was haben Sie dann getan?
Julian Weinberg: Dann kam eine Verordnung...alle Juden mussten die Stadt verlassen, um sich nach dem Ghetto zu...hm,...
David Boder: Zu begeben.
Julian Weinberg: . . . zu begeben. Ja.
David Boder: Sprechen Sie Jiddisch lieber?
Julian Weinberg: Das ist ganz egal.
David Boder: Also, beschreiben Sie uns...als ein intelligenter Mensch, als ein Ingenieur, beschreiben Sie uns das Lodzer Ghetto.
Julian Weinberg: Also bevor wir noch in das Ghetto gegangen sind, da haben wir bekommen früher...zuerst solche...eine gelbe Armbinde, damit man uns auf der Strasse als Jude unterscheidet. Und dann war das noch zu wenig für die Deutschen, haben sie uns dann solche gelben Sterne angeklebt von vorne und von hinten, damit man von allen Seiten bemerkt, dass da ein Jude geht. Natürlich war der ganze Verkehr in der Stadt für die Juden fast unmöglich, weil die wurden von den Deutschen, hm, auf der Strasse, so verschiedene, ganz gewöhnliche Arbeiter wurden von den Deutschen genommen, unabhängig davon wer das ist, ob das ein Arbeiter oder ein Intelligenter ist, musste er die schwersten Arbeiten ausführen.
David Boder: Was für Arbeiten haben Sie ausführen müssen?
Julian Weinberg: Ich musste, zum Beispiel, Fußboden scheuern eines Tages.
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: Ich hatte noch einen Fall, als meine Mutter am fünften (5.) März gestorben ist und ich musste sie beerdigen. Da war ich der Einzige auf dem Friedhof; niemand durfte die Leiche begleiten ans Grab. Und als ich vom Friedhof zurück kehrte wurde ich auf der Strasse aufgefangen von einem jungen Volksdeutschen und in ein Tor geschleppt und auf dem Hofe musste ich Kohle von einem Fuhrwerk nach dem Keller tragen.
Julian Weinberg: Und das dauerte ein paar Stunden. Da war...
David Boder: Und...
Julian Weinberg: Das war genau als ich vom Friedhof nach Hause mich begeben wollte.
David Boder: Also, Herr Weinberg, wollen wir das klar haben, also einfach ein Junge, nicht ein Offizier, nicht ein Beamter...
Julian Weinberg: Nein.
David Boder: Einfach ein...
Julian Weinberg: Das war ein junger...so ungefähr ein und zwanzig (21)...ein junger Mann...
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: Mit einer Peitsche.
Julian Weinberg: Hat er mich auf der Strasse aufgefangen und in ein Tor geschleppt in ein Haus.
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: Und dort waren noch andere Juden; es waren angesammelt zirka fünfzehn (15) Mann und alle mussten Kohle schleppen.
David Boder: Für wen hat man die Kohle geschleppt? Was es eine Behörde oder war es private...
Julian Weinberg: Das war für die nationale sozialistische Volksorganisation, also N S V.
David Boder: Ja. Und die haben einfach...
Julian Weinberg: N S V .
David Boder: . . . Leute auf der Strasse aufgehalten?
Julian Weinberg: Ja.
David Boder: Und gezwungen zu arbeiten.
David Boder: Nun?
Julian Weinberg: Als die Arbeit fertig war...
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: . . . da wurden Mehrere nach Hause gelassen. Aber mich...wenn sie erfuhren ich bin Ingenieur,...
Julian Weinberg: . . . haben sie mich zurück gelassen und ich musste noch zwei (2) Stunden länger bleiben, weil sie mich als Intele...als Intellektuellen betrachtet haben. Und ich musste noch zwei (2) Stunden noch Kohle, hm,...
David Boder: Schleppen.
Julian Weinberg: . . . schleppen die Kohle, ja, von einem Keller in den Anderen, so eine unbrauchbare Arbeit eigentlich musste ich ausführen.
David Boder: Ach so, das war bloß Schikanerie?
Julian Weinberg: Ja, das war eine reine Schikane...
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: . . . und dann erst in den späten Abendstunden konnte ich nach Hause gehen.
David Boder: Hm.
Julian Weinberg: Überhaupt auf der Strasse war es ganz gefährlich für die Juden, weil jeder konnte...konnte mit uns machen, was er nur wollte. Das ist nur eine kleine Episode, die ich kurz vor dem, hm, dem Übertritt in das Ghetto hatte. Nun...
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: . . . war es beschlossen, dass eigentlich die...das nach dem Lodzer Ghetto...sollte man eigentlich organisiert gehen. Also jeden Tag sollte ein bestimmtes Stadtviertel übersiedelt werden.
David Boder: Bei den Deutschen?
Julian Weinberg: Bei den Deutschen, ja. Hm, dort wo ich wohnte ungefähr—dieses Stadtviertel sollte zuerst gehen. Also...
David Boder: War das ein besseres Stadtviertel?
Julian Weinberg: Das war ein besseres Stadtviertel, ja. Und, hm, Punkt um siebzehn (17) Uhr wurde unser Haus durch SS Mann...
David Boder: Umzingelt?
Julian Weinberg: umzingelt und alle Juden mussten das Haus verlassen. Also die SS Männer, die kamen direkt in die Wohnungen, wo Juden wohnten; haben...haben...haben uns nur fünf (5) Minuten Zeit gegeben damit wir sofort die Wohnung verlassen. Also jeder hat...konnte nur mitnehmen das Allerwenigste, was er hatte in einem Rucksack, um...um sich nach draußen auf den Hof zu begeben. Mit meinem Sohn hatte ich auch so einen Fall. Er hat so ein arisches Aussehen. Da hatte er Peitschen bekommen, weil er mit dem Vater mitgehen wollte. Ihm glaubte der SS Mann nicht, dass er Jude ist. Und er dachte, er wollte sich mit den Juden mit schmuggeln. Nun ich musste erst feststellen, dass das mein Sohn ist, dann hat man ihn auch mit genommen.
David Boder: Na, für welches „Glück“ wollte er sich mit den Juden mit schmuggeln?
Julian Weinberg: Na, er wollte mit den Eltern gehen.
David Boder: Na ja, ich sage aber, warum soll der SS Mann denken, dass er absichtlich ins Ghetto gehen will?
Julian Weinberg: Aha. Ja, er wusste nicht, er hat vielleicht gedacht, das ist ein Arier, nicht wahr. Dass er vielleicht zufällig...das war ein, hm, Junge—er war damals so zirka, hm, hm, fünfzehn (15) Jahr, nicht wahr.
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: Ein kleiner...kleiner Junge, nicht wahr. Da dachte der, er hat sich verlaufen.
David Boder: Aha. Nun?
Julian Weinberg: Nun, es war im Winter, es war frostig. Da hat man uns wieder gesammelt auf einem Hof.
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: Die haben so von verschiedenen Häusern aus diesem „Quartier“ [Herr Weinberg spricht das französisch aus]—aus diesem Viertel...
Julian Weinberg: . . . die Juden angesammelt und wir wussten nicht genau wohin sie uns führen.
David Boder: Sie führen werden.
Julian Weinberg: . . . sie führen werden.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mal, Herr Weinberg, ich möchte natürlich alles hören, was Sie sagen. Aber Sie wollen mir bloß eine halbe ( ½ ) Stunde geben.
Julian Weinberg: Ja.
David Boder: Und darum möchte ich zu ein paar anderen Fragen kommen. Wie lange waren Sie im Ghetto?
Julian Weinberg: Im Ghetto war ich über fünf (5) Jahre, die ganze Zeit. Also ich wollte nur kurz sagen...
David Boder: Ja, bitte sagen Sie mir alles...[unverständlich; beide sprechen]
Julian Weinberg: . . . nachher...nachher, wie wir sind nach dem Ghetto gegangen, haben wir erfahren, dass am selben Tag—die selben SS Männer, dort wo sie in eine Wohnung nicht gleich rein gelassen wurden...
David Boder: Hm.
Julian Weinberg: . . . da haben sie die Türen aufgebrochen...
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: und wo Kranke liegen, liegten und die nicht mit gehen konnten...
Julian Weinberg: . . . haben die die kranken Leute erschossen.
David Boder: Also wie hat das gekommen...[unverständlich; beide sprechen]
Julian Weinberg: Also nachdem, nachdem...man erfahren hat...
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: . . . dass sie mit solchen Mitteln nach dem Ghetto treiben wollen, dann sind schon in den nächsten Tagen alle Juden selbst...selbst nach dem Ghetto gegangen.
David Boder: Hm.
Julian Weinberg: Also, das sollte dauern, sagen wir eine Woche und in zwei Tagen habe alle Juden selbst die Stadt verlassen, weil sie haben gesehen mit welchen schroffen Mitteln, hm, die Juden behandelt werden. Also wir wurden zu Fuß nach dem Ghetto gebracht—darunter waren viele junge Mädels, alte Frauen in Hausschuhe, manche sind auch barfuss gelaufen...auf dem Schnee. Unterwegs müssen Viele auch die Rucksäcke weg schmeißen, weil es war ihnen zu schwer die Last zu tragen.
Julian Weinberg: Nun sind wir nach dem Ghetto gekommen. Das Ghetto Lodz war vollständig isoliert von der Stadt.
David Boder: Was war es denn?
Julian Weinberg: Es war absolut keine Verbindung mit der Stadt. Es war umzingelt mit Draht...
David Boder: Aber es war in der Stadt?
Julian Weinberg: Es war an der Peripherie der Stadt. Man hat ausgewählt die Altstadt.
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: Das schlimmste Viertel der Stadt.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Julian Weinberg: Das wurde den Juden zugeteilt. Und es wurde rings rum mit Stacheldraht umzingelt und mit Polizeiwache streng bewacht, damit niemand das Ghetto verlassen kann und damit überhaupt keine Verbindung mit der Stadt möglich ist. Also anfangs hieß es, dass...von uns lebten die Leute noch. Jeder hatte etwas Geld, was sie mitgenommen. Und Manche haben auch etwas Esswaren mitgenommen, etwas Lebensmittel und man konnte so die ersten paar Tage durchbringen. Später hat sich formiert eine sogenannte Ghetto-Verwaltung. Die Ghetto-Verwaltung war eigentlich eine Form von der...hm, Stadtverwaltung.
David Boder: Ja. Was meinen sie mit eine...?
Julian Weinberg: Eine Abteilung...
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: . . . eine Abteilung war von der Stadtverwaltung.
Julian Weinberg: An der Spitze der Ghetto Verwaltung stand der bekannte Bieburg.
David Boder: Riebuck?
Julian Weinberg: Bieburg.
David Boder: Ein Jude?
Julian Weinberg: Nein, das war ein Deutscher aus Bremen.
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: Ein Kaufmann.
David Boder: Wie schreiben Sie seinen Namen?
Julian Weinberg: B-...
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: . . . i-e-b-o-w.
David Boder: Bieloff? Ja, nun? Er war ein Kaufmann aus Bremen?
Julian Weinberg: Ja. Und er hat übernommen die ganze Verwaltung. Nun hieß es, die Juden müssen im Ghetto arbeiten, sonst werden sie nicht leben können. Sie müssen auch ihre Existenz verdienen.
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: Na, da wurden verschiedene „Departements“ [Herr Weinberg sagt es auf französisch] geschaffen, verschiedene Abteilungen, wo dann die Juden arbeiten mussten. Also sagen wir ein Kleider [unverständlich]...
Julian Weinberg: . . . wo man verschieden Kleidungsstücke ausführt...die Schneiderabteilungen. Dann waren eine Metallabteilung, einen elektrotechnische Abteilung, hm, Teppichabteilungen., Verschiedene. Die Leute, die nicht...die kein Fach besaßen mussten sich umschulen, um etwas zu tun. Natürlich wollten die Juden doch nicht für die deutsche Macht arbeiten. Sie haben nur etwas getan, um den Schein zu geben, als ob sie arbeiten. Sonst hätten wir überhaupt keine Lebensmittel von den Deutschen bekommen. Und schließlich war die jüdische Arbeit die Billigste—hat sich den Leuten, den Deutschen, gelohnt diese verschiedenen Resorts zu schaffen, obwohl die Arbeit nicht sehr intensiv war.
David Boder: Obwohl die Arbeit nicht so intensiv war, ja?
Julian Weinberg: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: Und die war nicht intensiv, weil die...unsere Juden wollten direkt nicht arbeiten für die Deutschen. Es war also eine...eine stille Sabotage gegen die Deutschen. Hm. Die Ghetto Verwaltung hat eigentlich doch die besten...sehr gute Geschäfte gemacht, weil sie haben diese Sachen, die im Ghetto verarbeitet wurden, haben diese auf dem linken Markt verkauft, zum Beispiel:...
David Boder: Auf dem schwarzen Markt.
Julian Weinberg: Auf dem schwarzen Markt.
David Boder: Wie haben Sie das genannt? Der Linke?
Julian Weinberg: Dem schwarzen Markt, ja.
David Boder: Aber was war das andere Wort dafür?
Julian Weinberg: „Linke“ Markt.
David Boder: War das ein Ausdruck dafür?
Julian Weinberg: Ja, Manche nennen es „links“.
David Boder: Ja, das ist in Ordnung, ich will das nur wissen. Nun...?
Julian Weinberg: Auf dem schwarzen Markt haben sie es verkauft ohne Gewerbescheine, nicht wahr. Ohne Scheine.
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: Zum Beispiel...unser...unsere, hm,...Holzabteilung.
Julian Weinberg: Haben wir zum Beispiel ausgeschoben sehr viele Möbelstücke...
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: . . . und Kinderbettchen.
Julian Weinberg: Das haben die ohne Scheine verkaufen können, deshalb hat es sich gelohnt, diese Werke zu führen, ja, ja.
David Boder: Hm.
Julian Weinberg: Wir haben doch eigentlich...wir haben kein Geld bekommen, nur Lebensmittel und sehr wenig. Der beste Beweis dafür ist, Tausend von Menschen mussten hungern.
David Boder: Nun?
Julian Weinberg: Durch das Lodzer Ghetto gingen durch über zwei hundert tausend (200000) Menschen. Es waren hauptsächlich polnische Juden, es wurden auch aber im Lodzer Ghetto aus Deutschland, aus Österreich und aus der Tschechoslowakei Juden her gebracht—ungefähr fünfzehn tausend (15000) Juden.
David Boder: Hm.
Julian Weinberg: Und gerade diese Leute, die konnten sich so schnell nicht an diese schweren Lebensbedingungen im Ghetto gewöhnen und da kann man sagen, dass neunzig (90) Prozent dieser Juden, die aus dem Westen kamen,...
David Boder: Die vom Ausland kamen...
Julian Weinberg: . . . die aus dem Westen kamen, die waren, die mussten den Hungertod mit machen. Auch die polnischen Juden, speziell die Frauen und die älteren Leute, konnten auch nicht mitmachen die schweren Bedingungen und an Hunger und an verschiedenen epidemischen Krankheiten, wie Fleckfieber, Bauchtyphus und Andere sind Viele gestorben. Außer diesen normalen Standardfällen, wenn man das „normal“...
David Boder: Nennen.
Julian Weinberg: . . . nennen kann...
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: . . . hm, waren diese vielen Deportationen. Es hieß einfach, dass die Deutschen Leute brauchten zu verschiedenen Arbeiten. Und so viele Leute, die sich schlecht gefühlt haben im Ghetto, die dachten, außerhalb wird es besser sein. Sie gingen zur Arbeit, aber sie kamen nicht mehr zurück. Viele Deportationen wurden bei uns ausgeführt durch die Behörden und zwar durch die Gestapo in Verbindung mit dem Rassenamt. Die Dispositionen, wie uns bekannt wurde, sind aus Berlin gekommen. Und so hieß es—man muss jetzt zehn tausend (10000) Mann deportieren—immer hat es geheißen ‚zur Arbeit’. Aber die Leute sind nie mehr wieder gekommen. Eines schönen Tages haben sie die sogenannte Dienst-Sperre in unserem Ghetto eingeführt.
David Boder: Dienst-Sperre?
Julian Weinberg: Dienst Sperre.
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: . . . eingerichtet. Da kamen die SS Leute...Evakuierung...alle Leute mussten runter. Es wurde eine Selektion gemacht, wer evakuiert werden sollte und wer bleibt. Also Frauen und die Männer, die schlecht ausgesehen haben, die wurden auf Autos und Lastwagen geladen und nach Sammelstellen gebracht. Dort kam der sogenannten „Rollkommando“...Rollkommando.
David Boder: Hm.
Julian Weinberg: Das waren SS Leute auf schweren, großen Lastautos mit Anhänger. Dort wurden alle Juden...
David Boder: Anhänger heißt „trailer“, ein zweiter Wagen.
Julian Weinberg: Ja, ein zweiter Wagen. Diese Leute wurden gepackt auf diese Autos und weg geschafft. Auch wurden die Spitäler von den Schwerkraken befreit. Die Kinder wurden aus den Spitälern und aus den Kinderheimen raus geschafft.
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: Manche wurden direkt auf die Autos geschmissen, nicht wahr und das alles so raus geführt.
David Boder: Haben Sie das selbst gesehen?
Julian Weinberg: Das habe ich selbst gesehen, ja. Und interessant ist das, dass später die Kleidungsstücke von diesen armen Leuten, die weggebracht wurden, sind die selben alten Kleidungsstücke wieder nach...ins Ghetto zurück gekommen. Also als später...
David Boder: Zu welchem Zweck?
Julian Weinberg: Diese alten Kleidungsstücke sollten dienen...für diese Juden, die noch geblieben sind.
Julian Weinberg: Wir blieben doch im Ghetto über fünf (5) Jahre. Aus diesen alten Kleidungsstücken, aus diesen alten Schuhen, die zerrissen zurück kamen, weil die haben gesucht verschiedene, hm,...Wert...Wertgegenstände in den Kleidungsstücken, darum waren die Kleidungsstücke zerrissen, aufgeflickt. Auch die Schuhe wurden in unserem Ghetto...wurden die besseren Sachen hergerichtet und dann teilweise an die über gebliebene Bevölkerung im Ghetto verteilt und teilweise wurde auch das noch von den Deutschen raus geschafft für die Bombardierten, die bombardierte deutsche Bevölkerung.
David Boder: Nun, hm, und sie waren ganze fünf (5) Jahre in dem Ghetto?
Julian Weinberg: Jawohl.
David Boder: Haben Sie sich an der Gemeinde beteiligt?
Julian Weinberg: Ich habe mich in der Gemeinde selbst wenig beteiligt, denn bei uns war so ein Ältester der Juden...
David Boder: Was war der Name?
Julian Weinberg: Er war sehr selbstständig...Rumkovski.
David Boder: Was?
Julian Weinberg: Rumkovski.
David Boder: Ja, ich habe den Namen schon von Anderen gehört.
Julian Weinberg: Jawohl. Er hat die Befehle bekommen, direkt von der Ghetto-Verwaltung und er hat selbst die Befehle ausgeführt, soweit es in seiner Macht war. Ich wollte mich direkt an diesen Sachen nicht beteiligen,...
David Boder: Lebt er noch?
Julian Weinberg: . . . weil ich ein Gegner der ganzen Politik war und ich musste mich fern von dieser ganzen Sache halten. Hier...
David Boder: Lebt Rumkovski noch?
Julian Weinberg: Nein, Rumkovski lebt nicht mehr.
David Boder: Wer...
Julian Weinberg: Er wurde vernichtet von den Deutschen in Auschwitz. Die letzte Evakuierung war im Monat August neunzehn hundert vier und vierzig (1944). Also dann kam der Oberbürgermeister von der Stadt und auch der Amtsleiter von der Ghetto-Verwaltung. Sie haben Reden gehalten, sie haben gesagt, dass jetzt hat sich in Deutschland die ganze Politik geändert . Deutschland braucht Hunderte zur Arbeit, Deutschland wurde bombardiert, viele deutsche Städte wurden vernichtet. Diese Städte muss man wieder aufbauen und deshalb müssen auch die jüdischen Kräfte dazu...
David Boder: Benützt?
Julian Weinberg: . . . benützt werden. Dann war eine Kommission von Generälen, eine...eine Militärkommission und die haben beschlossen, dass Lodz befinde sich in der Nähe der Front...
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: . . . und man werde nicht in der Nähe der Front so viele Juden halten. Das ist nicht richtig. Sie wollen, sie wollen den Juden helfen...
Julian Weinberg: . . . eigentlich, weil sie sollen nicht in der Nähe der Front bleiben und deshalb haben wir verabredet, wir sollen raus fahren und werden bessere Arbeit und gute Lebensbedingungen haben und das eigentlich, das haben die, hm, mit so einer...Hm, mit so einer...
Julian Weinberg: Ja.
David Boder: Aufrichtigkeit? Sincerety!
Julian Weinberg: Aufrichtigkeit gesagt, dass die Leute dachten, die wollten die Leute überzeugen, dass sie bessere Arbeiten und bessere Bedingungen haben werden. Es hat sich aber raus gestellt, alle Juden evakuiert—nicht nach den bombardierten Städten, sondern alles ging nach Auschwitz, das ist das bekannte Vernichtungslager. Und dort in Auschwitz wurden die Leute wieder einer Selektion unterworfen und die Meisten mussten durch das Krematorium durch gehen und dort haben sie ihr Leben beendet.
David Boder: Waren Sie in Auschwitz?
Julian Weinberg: Ich war nicht in Auschwitz. Ich wurde...ich bin geblieben zwischen acht hundert sechzig (860) Menschen, die im Lodzer Ghetto über bleiben mussten. Das war eine Kolonne von den Deutschen gemacht, die das Ghetto ausräumen sollten.
David Boder: Hm.
Julian Weinberg: Aufräumen, das heißt diese Möbelstücke, die geblieben sind, diese noch alle Kleidungsstücke, Kissen und hm,...
David Boder: Kissen und bedding...
Julian Weinberg: Ja, das ganze Bettzeug müssen wir zusammen legen und das alles wurde nach der Stadt geschafft von den Deutschen.
David Boder: Nun.
Julian Weinberg: Das dauerte paar Monate. Wir, als die letzten siebzig tausend (70000) Mann, die nach Auschwitz gebracht wurden, wurde doch das Ghettostadt verkleinert und wir diese überbleibt...überbliebenen acht hundert und sechzig (8670) Mann und Frauen, wir wurden in zwei (2) Fabrik...hm, Wohnstätten...
David Boder: Untergebracht?
Julian Weinberg: . . . lokalisiert.
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: Die Männer in einem...in einem Fabrikgebäude...
Julian Weinberg: . . . und die Frauen in dem Anderen.
David Boder: Wo war Ihr Sohn?
Julian Weinberg: Mein Sohn war mit mir.
David Boder: Hm.
Julian Weinberg: . . . und meine Frau mit meiner Tochter waren...waren auf der anderen Seite.
David Boder: Sind die jetzt alle noch hier?
Julian Weinberg: Also man hat...Jawohl. Man hat uns direkt in diesen zwei Gebäuden lokalisiert das war eigentlich so ein Lager und von diesem Moment hat man uns betrachtet, wie ein Lager, wie in Auschwitz oder Dachau oder Andere. Wir waren unterworfen allen, allen hm, hm, strengen, hm,...hm,...
David Boder: Disziplin?
Julian Weinberg: . . . allen strengen, ja, hm,...
David Boder: Und Regeln?
Julian Weinberg: . . . und Regeln der, der Lager. Also jeden Morgen mussten wir uns auf dem Hof sammeln zum Appell...
David Boder: Ja.
Julian Weinberg: Da kamen die SS Leute, sie haben verteilt alle Leute für diese Arbeit. Dabei hat sich die ganze Sache bis neunzehnten (19.) September...bis Januar...bis zum neunzehnten (19.) Januar neunzehn hundert fünf und vierzig (1945), wo...an welchem Datum unsere Stadt von Russen und dann vom heranziehenden polnischen Militär befreit wurde. In den letzten Tagen, als wir sahen, dass sich die russische Offensive von Warschau herannaht, Sie müssen wissen, dass wir hatten auch ein verstecktes Radio im Lager. Da wussten wir ungefähr, wie sich die Sache verhält. Da haben wir...drei (3) Tage vor Befreiung der Stadt,...haben wir alle versteckt. Wir haben unser Lager verlassen und haben wir versteckt im Ghetto, was noch umzingelt wurde. Aus dem Ghetto konnten wir nicht raus, weil es war durch...
David Boder: Bewacht?
Julian Weinberg: . . . durch Polizeiwache besetzt.
David Boder: Das war nicht das Lager Polizei?
Julian Weinberg: No. Das Lager selbst hatte...hatte keine deutsche Polizei Wache—nur das ganze Ghetto. Wir sind nachts aus dem Lager raus und haben uns versteckt in verschiedenen Bunkern, in verschiedenen Kellern und auch in Dachböden der Häuser. Ich selber habe mich versteckt in einer Transformatoren Station. Das war ein Hochspannungsraum, wo ich meine Familie—insgesamt habe ich dreißig (30) Personen dort versteckt. Und aus diesem Grunde bin ich am Leben geblieben. Die Deutschen, wie wir später erfahren haben, sind auf unseren Hof gekommen und dort haben sie nur anstatt acht hundert sechzig (860) Mann, haben sie nur drei und zwanzig (23) Leute gefunden. Die haben einen großen Radau gemacht: „Wo sind die Anderen?“. Die Leute konnte darauf nicht antworten und sie haben gesagt: „Ja, die sind raus aus dem Lager.“ Da haben sie die drei und zwanzig (23) Mann verhaftet. Sie haben sie nicht erschossen, sondern verhaftet. Und sie haben beschlossen den Rest, über acht hundert Leute, die sich versteckt haben, haben sie beschlossen aus den Wohnungen raus zu ziehen und dann wollten sie eine gemeinsame...
David Boder: Exekution.
Julian Weinberg: . . . Exekution ausüben, weil sie haben schon von vorne herein—durch Juden—neun (9) Sammelgräber auf dem Friedhof ausführen lassen, und davon wussten wir. Und dort wollten sie uns alle hinschaffen und dann in diesen Massengräbern wollten sie uns vernichten. Also am ersten Tage, nachdem sie die drei und zwanzig (23) Mann verhaftet haben, es waren zirka hundert zwanzig (120) SS Männer mit Gewehre—haben sie uns aufsuchen wollen. Am ersten Tage haben sie zirka siebzig (70) Leute doch aufgefunden...zirka siebzig (70) Mann. Sie haben sie noch nicht erschossen. Sie haben sie auch zusammen mit den ersten drei und zwanzig (23) Leuten...haben sie auch verhaftet. Und sie sind gekommen am nächsten Tag...am nächsten Tag wollten sie den Rest auffinden. Nun haben sie auch Hunde mitgebracht. Mit Hunden wollten sie die Leute finden. Am nächsten Tag haben sie wieder etwas Leute gefunden, alle wieder verhaftet. Es verging noch eine Nacht und dann mussten sie schleunigst die Stadt verlassen. Und so...die rest...die restlichen Leute, die im Ghetto verblieben,...die haben sich auf diese Weise gerettet. Und auch diese Leute, die verhaftet, die wurden später von uns befreit.
David Boder: Ein Moment.
David Boder: [In English] This ends Spool 49, a report by the engi—...[ends abruptly]